Gone too soon, but not forgotten.
These beloved actors may have tragically passed
away, but their famous faces will light up
the screen one more time in 2024.
2023 has seen some particularly stunning losses
in show business, from "Friends" star Matthew
Perry, to "Brooklyn Nine-Nine" favorite Andre
Braugher to Albus Dumbledore himself, Michael Gambon.
But the most shocking loss may be that of
promising young actor Angus Cloud.
"At one point, I turned around and they had
the guns pointed at me, I'm like 'oh, smokes.'"
Known for his work on the hit HBO series "Euphoria,"
Cloud passed away unexpectedly at the age of 25.
The actor, who played Fezco, a drug dealer
with a heart of gold, was declared dead after
being found in his California home.
It was later revealed that the actor had suffered
an overdose of narcotics.
Immediately, wishes of love and grief poured
in from Hollywood and Cloud's co-stars, especially
the young cast who worked alongside the performer
on "Euphoria."
Before his death, Cloud's star was on the
rise — and as a result, he signed on to
multiple projects that will now feature posthumous
performances.
He already appeared in the 2023 thriller "Your
Lucky Day," which received a theatrical release
in November, and he's got two things in the
works for 2024.
Fans of the late actor will be able to catch
him in the horror flick "Freaky Tales" alongside
Pedro Pascal and Ben Mendelsohn, as well as
an untitled Universal Monsters movie featuring
Melissa Barrera and Giancarlo Esposito.
Fans of Ray Stevenson likely remember his
recent turn in the hit Star Wars series "Ahsoka,"
making the news of his passing all the more
tragic.
Stevenson was an accomplished actor who starred
on huge shows like "Dexter," "Rome," and "Black
Sails," appeared in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
as Volstagg in the first three Thor films,
and popped up in 2022's universally beloved
Telugu film "RRR," in which he portrays a
brutal British imperialist.
Sadly, Stevenson passed away in May of this
year while working on a project in Ischia,
an Italian island.
He was 58 years old.
Technically, Stevenson's first posthumous
performance came in "Ahsoka," which pays tribute
to the late actor, but he still has one project
upcoming in 2024.
Stevenson replaced disgraced actor Kevin Spacey
in the Hungarian action film "1242: Gateway
to the West," a drama about a priest managing
to stop an invasion by Mongols.
When it is released, it will mark Stevenson's
final performance.
Film and television fans are definitely familiar
with Lance Reddick, who was one of the best
parts of about a million different projects.
"We implemented Casual Friday, where employees
can wear jeans, once a month!"
"Well that was a catastrophic mistake."
Whether people know him from "Oz," "Lost,"
"The Wire," "Fringe," or even the cult comedy
favorite "Corporate," Reddick was an incredible
character actor with an enormous number of
credits to his name.
Sadly, Reddick passed away from heart disease
on March 17 at the age of 60 at his California home.
Co-stars paid tribute to Reddick's memory,
including his "John Wick" co-stars Ian McShane
and Keanu Reeves.
"Lance is a… was, is… a very beautiful
person, a special artist."
It's appropriate that "John Wick: Chapter
4" was one of Reddick's first posthumous roles,
as a spin-off movie set in the same universe
will also feature a performance from him.
Some of Reddick's other posthumous releases
in 2023 included the remake of "White Men
Can't Jump," "The Caine Mutiny Court-Martial,"
"Bosch: Legacy," and "Percy Jackson and the Olympians."
Audiences can see his final turn as Charon
, the concierge of the New York City Continental
Hotel when the John Wick spin-off film "Ballerina"
hits theaters in 2024.